hello welcome back to game sports
continuing coverage of e3 2015 we're
here with Chris and Jeremy from
Microsoft gentlemen what is this elite
controller you have just brought on to
our stage yeah so this is our new xbox
elite wireless controller it's built for
the demand that rigorous demands are the
hardcore competitive gamers we've been
working on in quite a while when we were
developing the original xbox controller
you know we made that as best we could
for all games all genres all hand sizes
but there was always these kind of 1%
people that always wanted something more
something that that they knew would help
them play more comfortably and be more
ergonomic and so we from that we talked
to those people and we went and talked
to them and find out what they wanted
with a controller and from that is uh
what we have here excellent you guys do
industrial design within Microsoft and
stepping back from this one so sort of
the xbox one controller what goes into
designing a control how do you like
research it was I'm yeah so for first we
talked to the gamers like we talked to
what's important for them for this we we
found people that were modding
controllers we went to this one guy went
to his garage he was drilling holes in
the bottom of his controller to put it
put a button there because he knew the
importance of never taking your thumb
off the right stay and so we talked to
those guys why are you doing this what
what what advantages it and we found
there's a ton of people that want these
types of thing they want taller
thumbsticks they want different safety
pads they want paddles they want a
shorter throw trigger and from that is
where a lot of the features came it must
be a lot of people to do it because like
you know third-party controllers have
always been a thing where people are
modifying the controller's also we see a
lot in the game spot offices of these
like plastic like faces that almost go
over the controllers that like sort of
change make it so you can create
triggers that actually just like trigger
the buttons that's obviously got its own
physical latency kind of happening so
there must be a lot of people who want
to do this is it just the pro gaming
scene or is it is it wider than that no
it's actually yeah I did so actually
it's this you know pro gamers were in
mind with this but it's actually for all
different types of gamers like people
that just like a different feel they
want something different maybe even for
like an accessibility standpoint there's
things that might be better for them but
it's really for all types of gamers that
know what they want and know what feels
better for them yeah so let's talk about
the details we got a couple of Commerce
here we can zoom in on it and so the
design itself you can break elements
apart and like customize it yourself
yeah a big part of what we wanted to do
with this was customized it so that like
Jeremy said gamers can make it what they
want they can get exactly what they want
out of it so we made all these
attachments magnetic it comes with
several d-pads several different heights
of thumb sticks these paddles on the
back come out magnetically really easily
you can put them you know in a couple
different places to customize it to your
hand size and how you want to hold the
controller one of the other cool things
that we added was this over molded grip
so it's an over molded rubber part with
a diamond grip texture feels really
comfortable in your hand and we we
wrapped it up around the outside because
we know people clutch the controller on
the outside like this it frees up their
fingers to use the paddles here and we
put this smooth soft touch paint on the
top so it its grippy but it's not it's
not going to stick your hands there you
still can slide around and you know be
comfortable playing for a long time and
my favorite aspect I think is because I
enjoy driving games a lot and what I
liked about the xbox controller what
Forza was it gave me a little bit more
feedback then and what normal
controllers do I go with steering wheel
all the time because I can feel the grip
of the tire and you can feel the
throttle and on that but you can hot
swap between like triggers and also the
the throttle on this way yeah so these
could be be used for for whatever you
want right that you can remap any any of
the ABX y el configures bumpers & poor's
it's a perfect example where we see
people you know take them off and
they'll use two paddles or three if they
want to use a clutch and they'll use up
shift here yeah it's here and it enables
people to play it play in a way that
that they might not have been able to do
before because they can take advantage
of using these fingers so is there an
application on the xbox one which allows
you to do the cut the customization of
the controller itself or is it on a
game-by-game basis yes go ahead Craig's
act they'd say the first time you
connect this to your xbox one it will
download the customization app it will
let you customize not just the assigned
functions to the paddles but really
remap any of the controls in any way you
want it and what's cool is it you can
actually save two of those profiles to
the controller there's a profile switch
here
you can switch back and sleep between
them you know during gameplay it's it
you put it right on the controller so
you take it to your buddy's house it's
locked there you've got your you've got
your settings that go with you yeah the
cool thing is if you go to your buddy's
house and you realize you want a
different profile so with the app you
can save 255 profiles in the cloud well
it's a lot more than enough more than
enough but if you find there's something
that you saved that you didn't put on
there yo you sign in with your gamertag
you can actually pull in those settings
clear premier gamertag and reassign them
on any console is this going to be
compatible with thee because I know
Windows 10 now that the the wireless
controller with the real dongle is like
a nikka bottle here so yeah absolutely
yeah you can play on a pc with with the
wireless adapter or plugging in USB
cable yep I don't nothing about
industrial design I don't know what it
takes like I can just a bad bill a table
like this probably with carpentry and
what is it a bit of control like
controller like this that like pumps it
up to a hundred and fifty dollars like
how does what is it that's in this that
makes it so much more expand like twice
as expensive as a normal controller yeah
it is more expensive but you do get you
do get a lot with that so like I
mentioned there's there's three
different heights of thumb stick sets
that come with it two different d-pads
these four paddles this hair trigger
lock the app all that goes into goes
into that but it's also the the actual
materials that we use these are all
stainless steel so super durable
high-quality that's how we get the
magnetic attachment we've also added
this this plastic ring around the inside
of the thumbstick here so it's a harder
lower friction plastic it's never going
to wear out we you know duty tested
these for over a million cycles nowhere
at all so it's really built you know
more robustly really uh you know kind of
to the needs of the gamers were really
going to try and get the most out of it
band and you guys really getting really
nice bag yeah so we know like a lot of
competitive gamers of gamers they travel
around to play at their friend's house
whether they're playing in tournaments
and things like that so providing them
something that they can easily store
this in slip it in a bag keep all their
parts that are there to switch out it
was really important to include as well
presumably if you're making it and like
a controller with this grade that like
people are going to spend a lot of money
on
making sure that it is durable is it is
a Modi important thing I know like the
early xbox controllers there had some
problems after a while and there are
fixed and later on iterations at the
PlayStation 4 the DualShock 4 is I know
but their nubs on those rubbed off real
quick as well how do you stress test
this stuff isn't do you literally like
put it in a robot just happen like yes I
literally put in a robot they don't you
know that does this their precious that
presses the triggers the tests these you
know hundreds of thousands of times so
that you know we can be confident that
when people are really jammed on this
thing it's not gonna fall apart it's not
gonna fail for yet and what's like the
stress limit on that do you say okay if
it lasts for a million we're good like
if it breaks after three million yeah I
mean that it turns 30 right yeah it
depends on the button but yeah I mean it
isn't it's in the hundreds of thousands
it's the millions of pressure and one of
the things we did with this was we
really wanted to understand with these
type of gamers how often they were
pressing certain buttons yeah and we
actually we started measuring that for
this to create some different specs
where I how people were actually using
that to make sure like you know if we
extrapolated over a year or two that it
would meet those kind of standards yeah
so did you get it was there any
interesting data in there like what was
the like most pressed button what was
the least yeah the interesting thing
there is in one of the reasons we
develop this everyone's different yeah
right depending on their layout the game
they're playing what you know what type
of mode in a game they're playing really
changes how much they press the buttons
I always feel like my Y is probably the
one I'm using the list just getting it
getting in and out of cars and
occasionally changing a weapon that's
yeah yeah yeah and and that's those are
the reasons though the wise further away
and like in a first person shooter a lot
of times it's switch weapons or reload
we see a lot of people remapping why
specifically to the paddle so they don't
gotta realize anymore so it's right
there for them no more of that yeah
thanks very much guys for coming out and
showing us the xbox elite controller
when is it available it'll be available
in October for 149 99 awesome and I
would be completely irresponsible to get
you guys up here and not ask a question
that's been plaguing me for years what
the hell do you call the two buttons
here and here is it boxes and lines what
are the official names the so we have
some internal
funny names for but they're actually
this one is the View button and this is
the menu button view and menu you knew
and then you and menu all right straight
from the horse's Matthew and menu
gentlemen thank you so much for coming I
really appreciate your time at view and
menu here we go done we can put it to
bed and thanks very much for watching
the games buddy through show for we got
loads more games coming up right here on
gamespot com stay tuned